un citoyen à toronto à mississauga très
exactement marque gravel monsieur gravel
les chefs vous écoute vous voulez parler
des services en français pour les
minorités francophones hors québec on
vous écoute
bonsoir madame messieurs vivre dans une
minorité est un défi avec les récentes
coupes provinciale c'est devenu encore
plus difficile sur le plan fédéral s'est
pas obtenu non plus parce que le service
sont difficiles à avoir par exemple
demander à un préposé au bureau des
passeports de le rencontrer vous venez
de multiplier par dix votre temps
d'attentes
air canada avoir un agent de bord ou un
préposé qui parlent français de toronto
relève presque du miracle
malgré les plaintes les nombreuses
plaintes auprès du commissaire des
changes ne change pas ma question est la
suivante comment
et concrètement et quels outils
d'intérêt vous le commissaire aux
langues officielles pour qu'il puisse
enfin faire respecter cette loi est
donné à tous les francophones du canada
un service adéquat est équivalent aux
autres très clair comme question
monsieur vous êtes le premier à répondre
alors merci beaucoup pour la question
c'est un enjeu très important c'est
peut-être ça va être une surprise mais
le français c'est pas ma première langue
et je suis natif de toi et c'est grâce
une décision de mes parents anglophones
que j'ai appris le français on est une
école et mesure et je fais des grands
efforts j'apprends mon subjonctif malgré
les parfums de mes paroles j'ai toujours
essayé d'armures et m'a forcé
concrètement j'ai eu une réunion j'ai
organisé une réunion entre tous les
chefs de pratique fédéral pour régler le
problème avec l'université francophone
je vais appuyer j'ai fait un engagement
très clair après cette université et
j'ai proposé de moderniser à la loi sur
les langues officielles
merci madame mais oui merci messieurs le
grave c'est un question traitement
important parce que c'est trop longtemps
que nous n'avons pas m'organiser la loi
sur les langues officielles
on doit le faire
et dont le fassions pas ce que vous avez
demandé les réponses concrètes les
choses que je pense que j'étais
tellement breton c'est de donner vire le
commissaire de l'unc officiel le pouvoir
de punir plus de pouvoirs pour exiger
que tous les argens où dans le domaine
fédéral présenté les services à 10 k et
et est égale pour l'efs pour des deux
langues officielles dont le premières
années de mon mandat
merci madame et monsieur bernie oui
merci la question c'est très important
le fédéral devrait réinvestir dans ses
champs de compétence et c'est ce qu'on
va faire pour les langues officielles et
pour les autres services que le
gouvernement fédéral offre aux citoyens
vous avez ici des gens autour de vous
des leaders de partis qui vous disent
qu'ils vont investir dans le logement
social dans la santé dans l'éducation
ce sont des champs de juridiction
provinciale et nous notre politique
c'est de respecter la consigne
canadienne ne pas s'ingérer dans les
champs de compétence provinciale est de
redonner les ressources au gouvernement
fédéral pour s'assurer de donner les
bons services en français aux
francophones à l'extérieur du québec et
en anglais aux anglophones mais aussi
les autres services que vous avez parlé
tout à l'heure un gouvernement fédéral
formé dans ses champs de merci merci
monsieur bernier monsieur blanchet vous
savez les québécois savent ce qui est
une minorité parce que même si les
francophones du québec si je peux me
permettre de dire comme ça sans majorité
au québec on est très très minoritaire
en amérique
je suis allé en ontario il ya des gens
qui ont trouvé ça étrange mais les
francophones hors québec et les acadiens
sont nos frères et nos soeurs
francophone de l'ensemble du continent
et du canada je pense que le commissaire
aux langues officielles pour bien faire
son travail doit ramener la notion de
réciprocité
il faut que les communautés francophones
à l'extérieur du québec et les
communautés acadiennes est le même
niveau de service que les communautés où
la communauté anglophone historique et
précieuse du québec
il faut que les francophones au canada
et les acadiens et le même niveau
service que les anglais du québec
merci monsieur blanc cher monsieur singh
oui merci merci monsieur gravel peu la
question peut-être comme vous pouvez
entendre j'ai aussi un francophone mais
je suis fortement francophile
je n'étais pas chanceuse d'avoir aucune
classe d'immersion en français mais
abondamment l'enfance gmt
j'ai tombé en amour avec la langue
française la langue molière et je veux
partager cette richesse parce que
c'était en richesse dans ma vie dans ce
qu'on veut faire concrètement c'est de
moderniser la langue officielle de mieux
financer les services français parce
qu'il faut le faire
si le gouvernement peut faire quelque
chose de faire quelque chose et le fait
c'est une question du courage c'est une
question de volonté
on a la volonté parce que c'est
tellement important merci monsieur
cheikh monsieur trudeau merci monsieur
gravel pour votre question vous
souviendrez un comme moi longtemps de ce
que monsieur ford a fait 2 qui est venu
au pouvoir de couper dans les services
aux francophones
malgré qu'ils s'étaient dits pour les
gens quand il se fait élire mais c'est
ce que ça que font les conservateurs
nous notre su défendre les minorités
francophones en ontario et à travers le
pays on va continuer de le faire
on a fait un investissement record dans
les communautés francophones ou des
communautés de langue officielle en
situation minoritaire à travers le pays
et on s'est engagé à moderniser la loi
sur les langues officielles
on comprend la lutte que vous vivez à
tous les jours et on sera toujours avec
vous merci monsieur trudeau et je
remercie surtout monsieur gravel d'avoir
posé cette question merci j'espère ça
vous éclairer monsieur gravel
merci